قبل اكثر من قرن وتحديدا في عام
1917 قرر الكونغرس الامريكي تحديد السقف
الاقصى الذي يمكن للحكومه استدانته لكي
تتمكن من تغطيه العجز بين ايراداتها
ونفقاتها ويجري ذلك عبر طرح السندات
الحكوميه للبيع تحتاج الحكومه في حال وصول
الدين العام الى السقف المحدد الى موافقه
الكونجرس اي مجلسين نواب والشيوخ لرفعه
لكي تتمكن من الاقتراض من جديد منذ عام
1960 رفع سقف الدين تسعه وسبعين مره وكان
ذلك يتم بشكل شبه روتيني رغم ما يحيط به
من سجالات في التاسع عشر من يناير الماضي
وصلت البلاد الى سقف الدين البالغ واحد
وثلاثين تريليونا و400 مليار دولار لكن
الكونغرس ورغم المفاوضات المستمره بين
اداره بايدن الديم
والاغلبيه الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب يعجز
حتى اليوم عن التوصل الى اتفاق بشان رفع
سقف الدين العام ما يعني ان الولايات
المتحده ستكون للمره الاولى في التاريخ
امام سيناريو العز عن الوفاء بالتزاماتها
الماليه والتخلف عن سداد ديونها لكن ما
تداعيات ذلك ان حصل يجمع كثير من
الاقتصاديين الامريكيين ان هذه الازمه
ستلحق ضررا فادحا بسمعه الولايات المتحده
وتفقد نظامها المالي موثوقيه الدوليه وقد
تتسبب الهزات الارتداديه لهذا الزلزال
المالي الوشيك في احداث ازمه اقتصاديه
عالميه لاسيما مع الضرر الذي سيلحق بسوق
السندات وارتفاع الفوائد على الاقتراض
وتضرر البنوك الامريكيه ذات الامتدادات
الدوليه التي تعد من اكبر المقرضين
للحكومه فضلا عن العجز عن تامين الاموال
اللازمه لرواتب الموظفين وخدمات الضمان
الاجتماعي والرعايه الصحيه وغيرها من اوجه
النفقات الحكوميه كما ان الاحتمالات لحصول
ركود حاد في الاقتصاد الامريكي ستزيد بشكل
كبير الامر الذي سيكون له حتما ارتدادات
عالميه وسط توقعات بان تفقد سوق العمل
الامريكيه اكثر من سته ملايين فرصه
وارتفاع البطاله لمعدلات قياسيه
[موسيقى]